hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we in round 12
of 2016 Tata Steel tournament our
compares today white is played by
fabiano caruana currently sitting in
second place in the tournament standings
first place being held by the world
champion magnus carlsen there's a point
difference between the two so fabiano
knowing that he only has rounds 12 and
three left he really needs to get some
victories even if his you know
counterpart magnus carlsen gets a couple
ties he can at least hi hopefully you
know Magnus Carlsen filters which
doesn't look like that's going to happen
so all in all he needs of victory his
opponent playing two black pieces
hometown hero Luke Fenway Lee we've
covered a few of his matches he's kind
of have a tough go he's played some of
the strongest players in the tournament
he's one of the weaker players just by
if you look at rating standpoint but all
in all looking to go out at the end of
this tournament with some strong a
matches so we're going to get started
with fabiano starting out with pawn to
e4 pawn c59 f3 pawn to d6 pondy for
capture capture and then we get into the
nigh Dorf defense so one of the sharper
lines the back and play usually results
in a pretty dynamic game and why has a
few options mainline typically to just
start with pawn to e3 but Bobby on
decides to go a little trickier rowdy
goes pawn to f3 pawn to e6 and then
Bishop here to e3 and this is a little
interesting because after pawn to f3
sometimes black can play Queen here to
be six and this sort of stops the bishop
from coming here to e3 because then
Queen down here taking on a b2 so
usually whites will if he wants to play
kind of this pawn here to f3 which
usually signifies he's not going to cast
on the King side he's gonna catch on the
queenside and really start an attack on
the on the King side usually he'll play
Bishop e2 e3 first and then pawn to f3
but Fabio decides to go and change it up
a little bit play spawn near to f3 you
know Luke does not decide to bring his
Queen out and set decides to play pawn
here to e6 so now queen or Bishop here
to e3 followed by pawn to b5 so look
says okay if you're going to start to
attack on the King side because
essentially I know that's what you're
going to do I'm gonna start to go ahead
and develop over here
on the queenside couldn't appear to d2
getting ready to castle on the queenside
night here to d7 and then pawn up here
to g4 so it's kind of a both castle on
the queenside starts to push forward on
the kingside pawn here to age six and
then castle on the queenside and now we
just start to to push starting pushing
forward with pawn here to h4 you know
eventually putting pawn here to g5
getting the rook over here to g1 if he
wants to attack push a little further
over here on the queenside though black
really needs to start to attack it's
gonna be tough he's going to use a lot
of his moves developing to maybe castle
on the kingside try to get somewhat some
sort of safety but by that time why can
kind of just blow up his King side so
he's going to be looking just all-out
attack on the queenside now black is
going to continue with Bishop here to be
seven and then pawn here to age 4 and
black kinda has two main moves here he
could start pushing first on the
queenside pawn here to be for makes a
lot of sensor he could start to just try
to protect this King over here if he
plays Bishop here to e7 then we're going
to see rook here to g1 allowing himself
to push forward with paneer to g5 it
gets pretty difficult if a flight
besides I'm just not going to worry
about you pushing 40 castles on the King
side then pawn to g5 it is pretty
difficult to deal with he kind of wants
to move his night but if he decides to
go ahead and take with his pawn we have
a recapture you could even recapture
with his Bishop either way the King
sides kind of blown up from a safety
standpoint now if he decides okay I'm
going to just play paneer to g5 we just
see take pond recapture we see the
bishop recapture all in all this is not
a safe way for black to defend his King
so he decides ok I'm not going to deal
with that I'm going to go ahead and push
forward here on the King side or the
queenside so pawn here to be for the
night moves here to a for Queen gets
involved into the game after pawn here
to be three just solidifying that night
then [ __ ] beer to e7 so it feels a
little bit safer playing this now and he
also doesn't have to worry about
castling on the King side but this just
gives him the option depending on how
white continues why continues with rook
here to h3 and then night down here to
see five attacking this night here at a
4
no I has a few options here his best
move is to play pawn here to a3 it's a
very tough move to really find though
because you kind of look at and say well
this night's already protected here on a
4 by the pond so does this pawn here on
a 3 really helped too much it really
does and we'll get into that but if you
kind of look at it it makes a lot of
sense to start continue just push
forward here on the kingside the Queen
side looks like it's somewhat defended
but right away black could just take
here on a4 after the pawn takes here
then black could say ok I'm not even
worried about castling on the King side
he can move his night here to h4 or d7 I
really like d7 just because he wants to
be attacking on the queenside so there's
no reason to just have your night
hanging out over here on h5 completely
separate from where you want to attack
so you know after this we could see the
pawn take right here if you wanted to
ponca take if you wanted to as well
Bishop could even take since he has the
defense by this Queen right here but
after the Queen takes it just doesn't
really look as clean from white he
doesn't have protection with his King
his Bishop over here is kind of isolated
by itself the rook here at age 3 isn't
really doing as much as you wanted to
and said that decides when he comes back
here that that pawn here to a3 is
actually probably the deferred way to go
now if the night were to come here to 84
he's not going to take the pawn taking
here on a4 first instead he's going to
take pawn here on b4 first and now after
the Queen moves he can take the night
here on a4 but only then so if the night
word to or the Queen were to come back
somewhere let's say Queen to see seven
or something and after the pawn takes
this is going to be a much better
position that white has onboard so after
the pond comes up here black doesn't
even want to take that night right away
instead decides to bring his work over
here to see eight putting more pressure
on the semi-open see file why it's going
to continue with the pond taking here on
b3 now after the night takes we see the
night down here and after the Queen
takes here at a for this is going to be
fine for white fabiano plays the king to
be too and he's pretty safe
the Queen's somewhat alone over here on
a four can't really continue to push too
much with an attack he has the Queen
here on d 2 which is protecting this
pawn here on before so all and all
definitely recognize that you although
you've wanted to push on the King side
it looks pretty interesting something
that a lot of players would probably do
he recognized hey it was probably better
to go ahead and protect myself a little
bit more on the queenside because I
still have this attack over here on the
King side whenever I want pawn here to
d4 and then Bishop here to see 5 in
[ __ ] go to c5 it was almost kind of
like he was waiting for this pond to
come here to d5 because this is a great
outpost for this bishop here on c5 if
the bishop were to take the nice just
going to come to this outpost right here
this is very difficult to deal with this
light square Bishop can't kick it off
none of the ponds can kick off anymore
so this is going to be extremely good so
nice little move from here fabiano bring
his Bishop here to see Five now Queen
comes back here to d7 and then now and
only now this fabi on the side he wants
to go and start pushing over here with
his pawn here to a g5 so we see an
exchange on board now the ribs going to
exchange our board and then a bishop
here to h h 3 you can see both these
bishops doing work this bishop right
here on h3 is kind of stopping the pond
from ever taking backer or moving really
from this e 6 square this [ __ ] right
here is a great outpost really just
controlling a lot of the board past kind
of this fifth rank right here so a
really good position from fabiano night
over here to age seven trying to just
put a little pressure right now on the
square here on d5 pawn to birji f4
completely stopping that and then all of
a sudden you you just have luke over
here with his night on h7 not doing
anything at all so queen here to a c7
now putting an attack on the square on
f4 and then the bishop decides to go
ahead and exchange on board and night to
a c4 so as we discussed once the bishop
moves now the night just continuously
takes the place of the bishop and has a
great little outpost here and before
Luke kind of had his night where he
could maneuver it to d7 and then
exchange the nights on board but is not
can't even do that for a while so this
nights going to be kind of a pain for
Luke to deal with for the rest of the
game Luke now plays pawn here to a five
just looking to break up this pawn this
outpost is too much to deal with punt up
here to g6 forcing the night to move
Knight to f6 pawn here to e5 just kind
of forcing this night to move around but
d7 is probably good square for him it
allows this outpost to kind of get blown
up a little bit decides to go ahead and
take with his night here on d7 knowing
that the pawn here I'm before was going
to fall so after the Queen takes we see
pawn appear to f5 and this is just all
sorts of chaos for black as far as how
he wants to defend this he probably
chose one of the worst ways he played
rook down here to see for maybe not sure
if he recognized all the threats that he
had going on in this position but rook
down here to see for if you want to take
the pond he can just take the pawn rook
down here to see for doesn't provide any
value could play Queen here to see seven
if you wanted to attacking the pawn here
on e5 that's pretty dangerous pawn but
after rook here to see four we see pawn
here to f6 check after the pawn takes we
see the pond take now he's kind of
forced to play king here to d6 now if we
were to play king here to f6 it just
gets really dangerous here we see the
rook here to f1 if the King were to move
the rook could just come up here to f7
he could decide to go ahead and take
this pawn here at g6 but then just gets
even crazier we have a checkmate in a
few moves you know King here to g6 the
King comes back here to h7 we get the
bishop involved all of a sudden we have
a checkmate so there's no great way for
the King to kind of dance around there
so he kind of forced to move king here
to d6 but then queen to h2 is maybe the
move that he didn't realize in the game
but it's just very dangerous king here
to c6 pawn up here to g7 getting ready
to promote his pawn to a queen that's
going to be bad so Queen back here to d8
stopping that attack a Queen to e5 just
centralizing that Queen on board Bishop
here to see eight trying to hold the
fort but not really doing too much
paneer to be five and the King can't
really take here because now the bishop
comes down here to f1 pinning down the
rook that the rooks going to fall this
is just all sorts of batsu
comes here to be eight now root coming
here to g1 didn't really have to play g1
he is trying to protect this we can push
forward with a g8 but he could just play
rook takes here on d5 if the Queen takes
we see an exchange on board pawn takes
now the pawns going to come up here to
g8 and get a queen on board know exactly
what happens with that if instead the
pawn takes then the Queen can come up
here to e7 attacking the king the
Queen's pretty much forced to come here
to e7 we see the pond take all of a
sudden why it's going to easily be able
to get a queen on board so blacks going
to fall there but decides to go for kind
of a safer out place rook here to g1 but
then queen to be 6 just says hey you can
just go ahead and get your free queen
I'm not even going to try to stop you so
pawn here to g8 gets the Queen and Lucas
forced to resign in this position so
fabiano great victory for him in around
12 magnus carlsen got a tie so fabiano
going into the last and final round is
only a half a point behind his opponent
madness Carl's pretty interesting
variation in the night off defense but
thank you guys for watching and I will
see y'all in tomorrow's final round